here at e3 and about to do and
Activision booth tour for the new policy
black ops 3 and eventually to be
telethon so who better to give me a boot
door and the man himself
[Music]
all right Vaughn what are we gonna do
we're gonna do a booth tour here right
look it's a big deal right
this is 12 years the franchise has been
around it's been a v3 before but it's
multiplayer has never been playable on
the show floor so it's a really big deal
for us to just put the heckler game in
the hands of the fans yeah and I'm
really excited because we get to show
them sort of what the experience would
be like for those who don't get to
actually come so that's really cool so
why did you decide to have a playable on
the floor I mean this is this is pretty
exciting
yeah so what's pretty understanding for
us is that you really just don't
understand the game until you play it
and as soon as you're playing it really
can kind of get your mind around it I
mean we talked about it you know we've
set it up and this whole experience that
we're gonna walk through real quick is
so that people can understand how we set
up the game so you're looking at the
different specialist
that's Seraph right there there's profit
on your right outrider is behind you
with the sparrow bow and arrow what's
your favorite it's my favorite right now
serifs really badass right I'm not
supposed to have favorites okay it's
okay I won't tell anybody don't think
that's true Nomad he's kind of the lone
survivalist not very social he's and has
no cybernetic augmentations at all it's
like the analog of the bunch and that's
the rusher ruin right there and all six
of these specialists are playable on the
show floor and there's three more that
are coming that no one's seen yet so
fans come through they queue up real
quick in this line with the idea just
sort of put them in the atmosphere of
the black ops 3 universe get a chance to
look at what the game might be like
before they actually get inside so this
it's the black ops 3 FG experience never
done 12 years here we are what a great
day oh my goodness are we gonna get to
play now yeah this is this is really
cool right so what we're looking at here
is four banks of 12 with a host station
on the end everybody can experience
whenever they want there's nothing sort
of hidden back here it's just all here
for players to enjoy
snuff for those diehard people they were
like I play like that's one every day I
think I feel to that look I've seen
people who are fans of black ops our
black ops to come and go I love it it
feels like this natural extension of
what I know but there's some fresh new
stuff here that makes things interesting
for me and you know the way that we
designed the combat loop it's a very
fast and fluid combat loop very tight
paced right so it's a very fast game and
the specialist spiking kind of changes
the dynamics of the match and then you
get a minute and people really dig that
kind of vibe
you're dead
okay
twelve and four-sevenths I'm ready up
Dave
thank you yeah you were second on your
after people get a chance to play a
couple of games they head on out here we
made up a hashtag it looks like I just
played bo3 our good friends will hook
everybody up I get with a black ops 3
t-shirt for playing and then this
beautiful beautiful screen
call of duty black ops 3 this is the
fact that is the black ops 3 booth
experience you believe you've been
working on this for three years
yeah I can believe it I can't believe it
feels like maybe six years
grape-flavored should work on Call of
Duty and so nice that you came to visit
with us you know the real question is
when are we gonna 1v1 yeah let me
practice up you go ahead we'll see that
they'll play inverted and with a
controller upside down
Gopala Judy let's see it this shirt Oh
it'll fit it's gonna fit real well
[Music]